social media is just really recently
taking off as a marketing channel so
what we're seeing is that sort of on
surveys among CMOS they say right now
social media is about 10% of marketing
budgets in 2018 is projected to be 20%
we're seeing that increasing amounts of
marketing dollars are getting shifted
from more traditional channels towards
social media more broadly so this would
involve both advertising through social
media as well as firms trying to kind of
foster consumers to talk about their
brands by providing platforms to leave
reviews by sometimes responding to them
and there's a lot of ways in which are
trying to do it so it seemed to channel
and if you ask CMO is about 64% of GMOs
think word-of-mouth online word of mouth
is one of the most powerful marketing
channels in the future but at the same
time it's actually not that well
understood how quantitatively strong
these effects can be and that's where
our study comes in what we try to look
for is and if you will an external shock
to the system something that changed how
much people were talking about a
particular product or brand that wasn't
related to any underlying
characteristics of the brand so if we
wanted to avoid us that your talk more
people are talking about a vent because
more people bought it in the past so
essentially the talking about is a
result of the sales but but we want to
establish is that where the talking can
actually need to more future sales in
that realm and that's usually hard to do
we looked at sina weibo which is the
chinese equivalent of twitter if you
will a very similar type of platform
twitter itself is blocked in mainland
china so it cannot be used so Sina Weibo
emerged as a substitute for that and
what happened is that in 2012 I'm
following a political scandal Sina Weibo
was partially blocked for three days and
so what we're investigating is we're
going to look at TV shows a lot of them
have a very active following a lot of
them are aired at a daily level so we
see every day people talk about these
episodes and they watch it at night and
suddenly for three days a lot of this
activity is gone due to this external
influence which is the censorship event
that's coming from the government and so
essentially looking at does something
happen to show us that tended to have a
lot of following and suddenly disappears
during those three days do we see that
being reflected in their viewership
numbers but the censorship event helped
us a lot in pinning something down
that's otherwise very hard to do so most
studies prior to that usually it's
something like relating sales of a
product to the number of tweets
pertaining to the product maybe from the
previous day or week something to assure
that's not happening at the same time
but even then it's hard to know whether
that's the right attribution so you
might imagine again the example there
might be one high quality product which
constantly has a lot of sales and
constantly has a lot of tweets about it
another product does not have that then
even if we look at temporal differences
between sales and the micro-blogging
that precedes it that might still give
us just a correlation rather than actual
an impact off the micro-blogging in a
causal sense onto the sales numbers and
it's a lot of reasons to think that the
if you will more naive approaches tend
to overstate the effect so the the
incorrect measurement would tend to go
towards overstatement rather than
understatement of the effect the reason
being that probably the most salient
reason is that the actual causal
relationship could be from sales to
word-of-mouth rather than the other way
around and this might be Mis attributed
so it could be the case that you sell
the product a lot and because a lot of
people buy
they then go on social media and talk
about it so it's really the sales that
precede the word-of-mouth rather than
the other way around which is what we
want to establish now in our case we can
rule that out because the censorship
event wasn't based on sales numbers or
anything it's really external to the
system and it impacts microblogging
activity and we can then trace through
the effect of that on to sales and we
can be sure that that reduction
microblogging does not originate from
sales differences which would be the
case if we just compare different
products with each other so what we find
is that relative to the typical movement
in TV ratings are doubling the number
doubling microblogging activity moves it
by about 20 percent of the typical
movement that happens from episode to
episode which coming from just one
advertising channel in this realm is
actually a fairly significant the
findings are significant in two ways so
one is I think both intuitively for a
lot of practitioners as well as in the
prior literature academic literature we
often thought these effects might be
even larger than what we find so to the
extent that firms increasingly shifting
their marketing dollars into those
channels it's very useful to know that
maybe these effects might have been
under overstated and we have to be
careful in sort of managing them
secondly it's it's a realm where it's
just incredibly hard to study these
effects because user-generated content
isn't under your control as a firm so
you can't manipulate it in order to
experiment around with it they actually
have to resort to methods like the one
that we're using which we call quasi
experimental we're not doing the
experiment ourselves but we have
something that is almost like an
experiment the Chinese government if you
will experimented for us by shutting it
down for three days they didn't mean to
shut it down for TV shows but it so
happened that's something that we can
leverage to actually understand the
effect it's a study that cautions a
little bit against overstating that is
sort of the magic bullet in terms of
marketing channels so it doesn't seem
like it's clearly outperforming other
channels so it seems to me of anything
we still want to stick with a certain
mix
of marketing tools rather than diverting
everything into that realm